una Reconciliación entre hermanos eso
simbolizó el paso de dos camiones de
carga por el puente internacional Simón
Bolívar que retomaron el paso comercial
transfronterizo tras siete años de
cierre parcial y tres de bloqueo total
un acto que el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro celebró
necesariamente las dos economías tienen
que integrarse estamos hablando de una
zona
especial
entre el táchira y norte de Santander
para que sea plataforma de la
industrialización
para que la calidad de vida sea general
y también homólogo venezolano Nicolás
Maduro en lo que definió como un día
histórico
estamos retomando relaciones y dando
pasos firmes para avanzar en la apertura
total y absoluta de la frontera entre
pueblos hermanos Colombia y Venezuela es
un día histórico y trascendental los
vehículos de carga podrán transitar
entre las 19 horas y las 6 de la mañana
y los peatones entre las 6 de la mañana
y las 18 horas con un flujo estimado de
30.000 personas diarias por ahora esto
Solo aplicará a dos de los ocho puentes
fronterizos El Simón Bolívar y el
Francisco de Paula Santander y aún no se
sabe cuándo podrán transitar vehículos
particulares con la reapertura Se
esperan mil millones de dólares anuales
de flujo económico cifra aún muy lejana
de los 2.400 millones de dólares en 2014
y los 7.000 en 2008 los habitantes de
ambas partes de la de más de 2.200 km
tienen esperanza
de la gente que se anima a pasarse por
el río por la necesidad e ir a Colombia
a conseguir lo que no hay acá en
Venezuela pues es muy bueno para los dos
países y en muchos sacrificio que
tenemos que pasar esperar a hacer cola
mojanos de todo ves con la reapertura
comercial además de los camiones se han
visto miles de personas cruzando ahora
el siguiente reto es analizar temas de
seguridad y de salud en la zona mientras
en Colombia la derecha Aún se opone a
este cambio por las acusaciones de
violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
pesan sobre el chavismo